el embarazo es el periodo de tiempo
durante el cual se desarrolla un bebé
dentro del útero
suele durar unas 40 semanas a partir del
primer día de la última menstruación
[Música]
estas 40 semanas se agrupan en tres
segmentos llamados trimestres
el primer trimestre dura unas 13 semanas
durante las dos primeras semanas no
estaba realmente embarazada pero es la
forma en la que se calcula su fecha de
parto
ya que su cuerpo se Estaba preparando
para el embarazo
durante la segunda semana se libera un
óvulo del ovario en un proceso llamado
ovulación
hacia el final de la segunda semana el
bebé es concebido en un proceso llamado
Concepción o fecundación esto ocurre
cuando un espermatozoide del Padre Se
fusiona con el óvulo de la madre
normalmente en las trompas de falopio
durante la concepción el material
genético de la madre y del Padre Se
combina para formar un código genético
único que determina instantáneamente el
sexo el color del pelo el color de los
ojos y cientos de otras características
esta nueva célula única llamada cigoto o
embrión es el comienzo de un nuevo ser
humano
durante la tercera semana el cigoto se
divide para formar una bola hueca de
células llamada blastocisto las células
del blastocisto comienzan a organizarse
en dos grupos
el grupo interno se convertirá en tu
bebé y el grupo externo formará tejidos
para nutrirlo y protegerlo
durante la cuarta semana el blastocisto
se traslada al útero donde eclosiona de
su capa exterior
una vez liberado de esta capa exterior
el blastocisto puede incrustarse en el
revestimiento engrosado de la pared del
útero en un proceso llamado implantación
la semana 5 a 10 se denominan periodo
embrionario todos los órganos
principales comienzan a crecer como el
cerebro la médula espinal y el corazón
el corazón comienza a latir durante este
periodo
las estructuras denominadas placenta y
cordón umbilical comienzan a
proporcionar soporte vital al embrión
llevan los nutrientes y el oxígeno de la
madre al embrión
los huesos y los músculos empiezan a
crecer bajo una piel fina y transparente
hacia el final del periodo embrionario
el embrión empieza a tener un aspecto
más humano
al final de la décima semana el embrión
pasa a llamarse feto y mide unos 3,18
centímetros de la cabeza a la rabadilla
durante la siguiente semanas los brazos
y las piernas se alargan y empiezan a
moverse los dedos de las manos y de los
pies terminan de desarrollarse y la cara
del bebé Está bien formada al final del
primer trimestre su bebé mide casi ocho
centímetros
su cuerpo experimenta muchos cambios
durante el primer trimestre Esto se debe
a los niveles cambiantes de una
sustancias químicas llamadas hormonas
que circulan por el organismo
el primer síntoma más común de embarazo
es que sus menstruaciones han cesado
también puede tener otros síntomas como
náuseas a menudo llamadas náuseas
matutinas Aunque pueden producirse en
cualquier momento del día pechos
sensibles e hinchados cambios de humor
estreñimiento
pérdida o aumento de peso
antojos o aversión a ciertos alimentos y
más cansancio que de costumbre
es posible que solo tenga algunos de
estos síntomas o ninguno
Si tiene alguna duda sobre el desarrollo
de su bebé o le preocupa Cómo se siente
hable con su proveedor de atención
médica